hey guys it's Kylie and Jordan mere are
Kylie Jenner and her estranged BFF
Jordan Woods ready to kiss and make up
just getting on ahead the former pals
had a massive falling-out in February
after Jordan was accused of kissing
Khloe Kardashian's now ex Tristan
Thompson for you and Jordan it's like a
divorce
she does now a source is opening up to
ET telling us that kylie is thinking
about rekindling her friendship with
jordan but she's going to be cautious
quote Jordan was Kylie's best friend and
rock for a very long time but Kylie is
loyal to her sister Chloe
that's just so crazy the girls
reportedly partied together recently and
et source says they were cordial to one
another which is a positive step in the
right direction quote it brought back
old feelings of the fun they used to
have together they aren't nearly as
close as they once were but both girls
are hoping in the future they can be
friends
you have to find the happy medium of
keeping your private life private
any personally you know it's just the
aftermath of the Jordan tryst and Chloe
drama will seemingly play out in the
upcoming episodes of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians mama Kris Jenner opened up
to et in May about going through these
tough times and sharing them with their
viewers well it's always difficult when
somebody goes through a rough time and I
think one of the things that has made
the success of the show is that we show
those vulnerabilities and we're also
transparent and you do see how it
actually unfolded in what happened
because everybody thinks they know the
whole story and they don't the rest of
the season has so many crazy things
going on and as I say every time you
guys ask it's just tune in because you
never know what's gonna happen
[Music]